Stranger Things 3 is finally here, along with
the Red Army, parasitic sludge monsters, and
more '80s references than you can shake an
ice cream scooper at.
Of course, '80s nostalgia isn't all you'll
find if you dig deeper.
Here are just a few of the small details you
might've missed in Stranger Things 3.
One of the earliest pop culture references
in Stranger Things 3 comes with Dustin's return
to Hawkins from summer camp.
Dustin tells everyone about his new girlfriend
Suzie, explaining that the only way to contact
her is his newly constructed ham radio, which
he nicknames "Cerebro."
"So it's a ham radio."
"The Cadillac of ham radios."
Anyone familiar with Marvel's X-Men will know
where Dustin gets the name.
In comics and movies and everything in between,
Cerebro is the device Professor X uses to
amplify his telepathic powers to find other
super-powered mutants.
With her psychic abilities, Eleven is the
character in Stranger Things most like Professor
X. Ironically she's one of the few of the
series' kids who isn't there for Cerebro's
unveiling.
Dustin gets everyone to agree to hike with
him to Hawkins' tallest hill so they can set
up Cerebro and contact Suzie, but Eleven and
Mike bail before they finish the climb, presumably
to find a good spot to make out.
Dustin's Cerebro ends up being a pop culture
reference standing on top of another pop culture
reference.
He doesn't use the name earlier when he leads
his friends there, but in the season finale
we learn Dustin has given a name to the hill
where he keeps Cerebro - Weathertop.
He says the name when Steve takes him and
Erica to Cerebro, speaking it as if Steve
should just naturally know what he means.
If your memory isn't that great or you're
not a Tolkien fan, Weathertop is a ruin atop
a hill in J.R.R.
Tolkien's Fellowship of the Ring.
Shortly after they meet one another, Aragorn
and the hobbits camp there on their way to
the Elven land of Rivendell.
It's where the heroes are briefly surrounded
by the RingWraiths, and where Frodo is stabbed
in the arm by the Witch King of Angmor and
corrupted by the undead warrior's blade.
As not only a self-proclaimed nerd but a Dungeons
& Dragons player, Dustin is definitely familiar
with the Lord of the Rings books, hence the
name he gives the hill.
And even if he wasn't big on fantasy novels,
he could certainly be a fan of the 1978 animated
Lord of the Rings film.
In the beginning of Stranger Things 3's fourth
episode, "The Sauna Test," Max offers Eleven
one of two comic books to read, and those
specific issues seem to have been chosen for
a few reasons.
Most obviously, they're accurate for the time.
Wonder Woman #326 was released in 1985 - the
year in which Stranger Things 3 was set - while
Green Lantern #185 came out in 1984.
Both comics end with the reveal of a villain
reminiscent of the Mind Flayer.
In Green Lantern #185, test pilot Richard
Davis unwillingly flies a jet into a giant
black column and inside he finds Eclipso - a
mystically parasitic supervillain known for
controlling and corrupting hosts, just like
the Mind Flayer.
Likewise, Wonder Woman #326 ends with the
emergence of an Aztec god who's described
as, among other things, "the god of the nocturnal
sky… the embodiment of change through conflict."
Both concepts are powerfully present in Stranger
Things 3, particularly the concept of change.
Stranger Things has always worn its cinematic
inspirations as badges of honor, and one particular
moment in season 3 proves that idea pretty
clearly.
When the Scoop Troop leaves the movie theater
while trying to escape the Russians, we see
a bunch of 1985 movies on the marquee, including
The Stuff, Return to Oz, DARYL, Fletch, and
Cocoon.
What happens in The Stuff?
Residents of a small town all eat a ton of
an addictive food-sludge called, well, "the
Stuff."
Turns out that the stuff is actually a parasitic
goop that takes over people's brains and turns
them into mindless zombies, before eventually
eating them.
"Just like the movie."
As for the other movies, Return to Oz includes
a batch of bad guys called "Wheelers," a name
they share with Nancy and Mike Wheeler.
DARYL is about a secret government science
experiment to create a child-like super-soldier
for the military, just like Eleven's training.
Fletch features a journalist who investigates
a bigger story after his editor tells him
not to, similar to Nancy's pursuit of the
story she hears from Mrs. Driscoll.
And Cocoon is about a bunch of aliens on Earth
disguised as humans.
Sound familiar?
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about Stranger
Things are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.